Welcome back!
Now, it's Oscar season
in Hollywood,
and many of this year's
great films
featured black actors
and directors.
Now, the Academy Award
nominations come out
tomorrow morning, so it's time
for our annual tradition,
A Preview of
the Upcoming Black Oscar Snubs.
♪ ♪
(humming)
All right, here to take us
through this year's list
is our own Robin Thede.
-(cheering and applause)
-Ah. Thank you, Larry.
Hey, Robin, how you doing?
Thank you.
Now, I hold in my hand
the names of the black
film stars and directors
who are going to be screwed out
of nominations this year.
Because the only black people
in Hollywood getting any love
are the ones
Sandra Bullock keeps adopting.
Oh, man.
All right, here we go!
The nominees
to be snubbed are...
Will Smith in Concussion!
Wow!
Oh, my God, really?
That's a surprise, Robin.
I thought white people
love Will Smith.
-They adore Will Smith, but
nobody saw that movie. -Yeah.
-Hmm. -Only white actors
can win Oscars
for a movie that nobody saw.
Wait, really?
Larry, you don't need to be
Stephen Hawking
to understand that science.
Got it.
All right.
On to our next black Oscar snub.
-Who we got? Who we got?
Who we got? -It goes to...
F. Gary Gray, the black director
from Straight Outta Compton!
Wow. Man! Oh, my God!
Wait, Robin!
That was a good movie.
Why isn't he gonna get
nominated?
Uh, he's black
and also a director.
But mainly 'cause he's black.
Aw. Man, are you sure
about that?
Hello? We get called angry
and loud for brushing our teeth.
You think you're gonna give
a black person an award
for screaming "Action!"
at Paul Giamatti?
Oh. Yeah. You know,
that actually does make sense
when you put it like that.
All right,
so who else won't be nominated?
-Okay. Our next non-white
non-nominee is... -Mm-hmm.
Creed star Michael B. Jordan!
Yes!
No!
Yes.
Wait, Robin,
why are you so excited?
He's not going to be nominated.
I know,
but it's still the Oscars.
Oh.
All right. So-so what's the deal
with him?
I mean,
he was great in that movie.
He's a black man
who punches people.
Does that sound like acting
to you, Larry?
Well...
I mean, most Academy voters
think Creed is a documentary.
Oh, come on, Robin.
Robin, that's unfair.
Look, Christian Bale won
an Oscar for The Fighter.
Exactly. As a good white boxer.
Now, that's what I call
a transformation.
All right, let's wrap up.
Who gets the last snub
of the night?
Oh, last?
Well, I have, like, 57 more,
-but, um... -Well, just go...
just go with one.
-Okay, if I have to pick one,
it is... -Okay.
-Oh, these are always so tough.
-I know. It's exciting.
...Kitana Kiki Rodriguez
in Tangerine!
What?
Oh, my God.
-That's a surprise.
-Now...
Rodriguez's haunting portrayal
of a trans woman was brave,
but it wasn't "Jennifer Lawrence
invents a mop" brave.
Well, but...
Robin, this is disappointing.
Rodriguez is transgender.
They've had a great year.
Why wouldn't Hollywood, like,
want to celebrate her?
For the same reason
the bear from The Revenant
is gonna get snubbed.
Wait, the bear? What?
Yeah, Larry.
She's brown, and she's a woman.
Two strikes!
Robin Thede, ladies and
gentlemen! We'll be right back!
-Should I be happy?
-(cheering and applause)